yeah house of the dragon episode 2 is
pretty freaking great i was a little
hesitant on the first episode about this
show being as good as the first four
seasons of game of thrones but episode
two really blew me away besides the best
scenes within the episode that i'll get
to later i think the direction of this
episode was masterfully done in respect
to acting cinematography pacing and
editing firstly let's talk about the
acting because holy [ __ ] the actresses
who played rainer and alison spoke
volumes with their performances in this
episode this also ties into the pacing
of the dialogue scenes but there were so
many slow moments that allowed the
camera to sit on a character's face that
let us see the subtleties of their
performance it really emphasized what
the characters were going through in
each moment and the fact that each shot
lingered on the actors and allowed them
to wow us with their performance made me
gush with the joy like the scene where
renera and allison are talking to each
other by candlelights about their mother
and father is a great example of this
there's an entire uninterrupted moment
where rainier is praying and it's just
breathtaking from her acting as she
breaks down and the music slowly feeding
in with a serene and happy tone uplifts
the seemingly normal moment to being
great and this isn't even mentioning the
gorgeous cinematography it's genius to
me that the scene was filmed next to
dozens of candle lights that eliminated
the actors faces like you see the
specular highlights within each of their
eyes as they're on the verge of crying
so even the cinematography is elevating
the already great performances and this
is just a normal chill scene that
doesn't even have major plot
significance that fundamentally raises
its quality because the plot point of
viserys having to find a new match to
marry further increased the intrigue
value of this episode this plot
development basically twisted a knife
into every character and was such an
engaging conflict because everyone had a
stake in it will cordless valerian
successfully marry off his daughter or
will other vultures swoop in and take
the prize the point of manipulation as
everyone is trying to persuade the king
into their own favor is like peak
political drama viserys being kind of a
pushover and a king that can be
manipulated makes for a perfect subject
in this regard it really shows and puts
a spotlight onto each character's
motivations and how grimy and slimy they
all are this was essentially what i love
so much about game of thrones so many of
those small council meetings that
showcase the colorful roster of
characters and their varied and
dangerous motivations really made
everyone fun to watch house of the
dragon is getting to this point with
otto hightower and cordless valerion and
there is still some time for the other
characters on the small council that
haven't been developed as much but to me
this conflict of finding a spouse is
also a perfect formula for creating
great dialogue scenes because it's
insanely layered on one hand we have the
conundrum of viserys not wanting to move
on then there's a dynamic vernier having
to accept the obligation that our father
has to remarry for legacy and then
finally we have everyone making a play
to seize the opportunity of power it's
just outstanding and it pushes every
character to a breaking point this
episode and even characters like lionel
strong got an opportunity to shine with
his own perspective but it would have
been nice if the writers were able to
write in a way to tell us the
significance of this character and a
little bit of his backstory because we
still don't really know who he is yet as
a point of comparison
cordless valerion had a great monologue
that thoroughly built him up as a
character by him diving into his
backstory but the genius thing about
this scene was that this monologue was
doubled as plot developments slight
spoiler and i'll start to mark any
spoilers with time codes just in case
anyone hasn't seen the episode but
cordless for lyrion relating himself to
daemon through his backstory and his
overarching pitch to form an alliance
with him genuinely impressed me because
it's really hard to work in a lot of
expository backstory and have it make
sense within a scene as natural dialogue
but this instance is a shining example
of it working and because of that fact
this was one of my favorite scenes in
the episode and on the subject of best
scenes we have the confrontation of
damon targaryen now this is probably a
favorite scene among everyone for this
episode and rightfully so because this
scene was essentially a master class in
suspense and tension firstly the music
in the scene perfectly aided the rising
heat and put everyone on edge although
rameen jawadi didn't make a new theme
for the title sequence which in of
itself was really sad and disappointing
he still created great music to
drastically rise attention here i even
loved the subtle editing move in which
the music for the confrontation scene
begins during otto hightower preparing
for the trip and then we cut the
dragonstone it really eases us into the
scene and it also does away with the
notion of fast traveling that was an
issue in game of thrones because here in
house of the dragon it feels like an
extension of the same scene and on that
notion the show is establishing a lot of
time jumps but the narrative still feels
very seamless so the time jumps don't
feel jarring in any way
getting back to the confrontation scene
though the cinematography and overall
design of this scene was also
intentionally orchestrated to further
punch up the suspense the thick fog
rolling over the characters and making
everything feel moody is really smart
especially since this was shot on the
volume and if anyone doesn't know what
the volume is it's a massive room with
led panels that essentially work as
real-time green screens that play
footage on the backgrounds within the
volume a small limitation is that you
can't really copy direct sunlight that
well because it's hard to match the
severe output of light from the sun so
the craters decided to set the scene in
a thick fog so this limitation of the
volume ended up actually aiding the
scene then going back to the aspect of
the pacing for a scene the shots where
we sit on ardo hightower's face and the
overall arsenal of reaction shots from
everyone made me feel even more uneasy
especially when the dragons start to
come out because man do the actors
illustrate how scared they really are
and the reveal of karaxis was so good
and i love that we first hear his squeal
before his visual introduction it really
emphasizes that oh [ __ ] this is about to
get really ugly and the shot of otto
hightower soiling himself is the cherry
on top again going into minor spoilers
the turn of the scene in which hernia
shows up was a great way to have her
gain some value in clout and prove to
people that she's really smart and brave
her dynamic with damon is really
refreshing and i like how they don't
just simply hate each other something
that i was kind of worried about in
episode one where damon might turn into
a generic villain but that worry has
completely vanished in this scene we all
see her near his new theme and i love
how they introduce it here because this
was essentially the first time she
proves herself so she's basically
earning her theme through this event
because of this that even makes her more
of a badass as she's proudly walking
through the red keep with her new theme
playing aloud and yet again this also
deletes my other worry that ramin jawadi
would use a frankenstein version of
daenerys's theme for rhonera so thank
god there's a new theme for her to
differentiate her a bit more another
aspect this episode does really well is
a political intrigue that was one major
aspect that game of thrones did
perfectly so it's really assuring to see
house of the dragon handle the political
sphere of westeros just as well all of
the small council meetings are like
crack to me because not only do these
scenes set up characters in the plot but
they also heavily develop the world in
general politics associated with the
characters the show feels very immersive
in this regard and it makes every
development that's revealed very
engaging because i just want to know
more and i love that they are putting
emphasis on the crab theater conflict
because this is something that's
impacting very specific parts of the
world like trading routes which normally
wouldn't really hear that much about but
having this detail within the world
makes it have even more depth which on
the subject of the crab feeder every
shot so far on the beach was beautiful
the shallow focus of crabs walking
around feasting on people is such a
unique site to see that it makes what is
probably a brief secondary antagonist as
being very memorable that in the design
of the crab feeder is very cool and i'm
excited to see what happens with him in
the next episode and since there will be
more action in episode 3 due to the
preview it's really nice to note that
the dialogue was able to hold up on its
own because going into the house of the
dragon i thought there would be a bit of
an over reliance on action and dragon
spectacle which thankfully that isn't
the case as evidenced by episode 2 which
virtually had no action and instead had
insane tension-inducing scenes that were
primarily driven by dialogue so the fact
that house of the dragon has proven to
have great dialogue scenes makes me
really excited to see how the action
portion of the show plays out like to me
this is the best case scenario for how
the show could have turned out in my
mind i'm genuinely at least for episode
2 struggling to find any major flaws
even the character who plays elena
valerion did a surprisingly good job
with what she had to do and perfectly
illustrated the doubt and hesitation
behind what she had to say to viserys so
for this episode i'm sitting at about a
9 from how amazing the acting
cinematography and overall writing was i
feel like i'm fully back into the world
of game of thrones and i hope the rest
of the season can retain the current
quality set by this episode thank you
for watching and let me know what you
guys thought about episode 2 of house of
the dragon